ce sourire traduit la fin d'un Calvaire
qui mène à 35 ans durant 3 années son
mari de la battue mariée en 2014 au
Cameroun avec cet homme qu'elle croyait
être l'homme de ta vie elle aura eu
trois enfants mais petit à petit le
prince charmant est devenu un monstre
quelques gifles et quelques coups et
enceinte
et peut-être j'aurais pu stopper ça au
début mais je me suis dit que peut-être
fait une erreur il a compris peut-être
après parce que après il s'est excusé
qu'il fera plus jamais moi j'ai compris
que peut-être ça lui a passé il n'a pas
pu se maîtriser et peut-être que c'était
moi aussi c'était à cause ce sentiment
de culpabilité exacerber par ses proches
jusqu'à sa propre belle-famille chaque
fois qu'on met des infidélités
ou bien on me fait comprendre que ça
fait partie de
foyer c'est ça qui fait en sorte que si
tu arrives à surmonter tout ça c'est ça
qui me tu es capable de gérer en couple
on a reçu durant ces années aucun
soutien qu'à chanter acte de violence à
sa famille par peur d'être jugé tu
voulais rester parce que moi c'était moi
le moins j'étais quelque chose de ça
crée une fois que vous êtes marié vous
devez tenir jusqu'au bout et j'avais
peur qu'on dise que j'ai échoué ma vie
parce que c'est ça chez nous parce que
vous divorcer mais pas fait les enfants
avec plusieurs hommes moi je vais tenir
jusqu'au bout si il fallait que je
puisse arriver pour mes enfants je le
ferai
à chaque retour de France où il vivait
une partie de l'année pendant 5 ans son
mari faisait subir une violence physique
et psychologique à Chimène pour lui la
femme doit faire le ménage et s'occuper
de ses enfants ce qu'elle n'acceptait
pas octobre 2019 suite à un regroupement
familial elle vient finalement
s'installer en France avec son mari 3
mois de cauchemar il s'appelle sur moi
ils me prennent une tirer par les pieds
et j'étais dans la chambre alors qu'elle
subit une nouvelle grossesse non désirée
elle trouve la force de prendre la fuite
en pleine nuit réfugier chez ses sœur
elle rend compte finalement une
assistante sociale elle trouve refuge
ici dans cet accueil de jour
départemental des Yvelines pour les
femmes victimes de violences
franchement j'ai été
accompagné je vous dis pas ce que j'ai
dis quand je suis arrivé et si j'étais
sans repère j'étais franchement j'étais
très à Mathieu s'il a beaucoup de
réconfort et vous accompagne aussi avec
les mots de procédure depuis Chimène à
porter plainte est enclenchée une
procédure de divorce le jugement est en
attente en janvier prochain si main
d'oeuvre est entrée en formation pour
devenir aide-soignante des centaines de
femmes victimes de violences comme
Chimène pousse la porte de cette
structure de travailleurs sociaux
spécialement former les accueille nous
avons la chance de travailler en
partenariat cela signifie que la
personne qui va à franchir notre porte
va pouvoir trouver au sein même de
l'établissement par des permanences une
aide qu'elle soit juridique ou bien
psychologique c'est centre financé par
l'État existe depuis 6 ans et a permis à
de nombreuses femmes victimes de
violences de les accompagner faire une
vie meilleure